so there's been a news story going
around the british media about a car
melting in london which apparently is
due to its proximity to a new building
which is going up in london the physics
is a thing called geometric optics and
this is about how you deal with
understanding how light propagates and
if you really want to do the job
properly then you've got to solve
maxwell's equations and really solve a
very complicated set of equations and
light's actually quite complicated but
for many purposes you don't need to do
that because essentially the main thing
that most people know about light is
that it travels in straight lines so the
story is that um some guy just parked
his car on the street went away for an
hour
came back and found that most of the
plastic parts of his car had melted
and there was actually a note i think
stuck under the windscreen uh saying um
uh your your car's melted please come
and see us from the builders of this
building who clearly recognized that
their building had something to do with
the fact that this car had been melted
so it's a new building it's not even
finished yet it's it's still going up
and actually there had already been a
few stories around about people being
dazzled in the streets and so on so it
was already people were starting to
think there's something strange going on
with this building but this was kind of
the
the really extreme case of all the bad
things that this building ended up doing
i have a bit of history in this i've
actually looked at the effects of
large reflecting surfaces um and that
the way they concentrate light and so i
started looking into this particular
story a little bit more closely one of
the nice things about new buildings
going up is of course they have to have
planning applications and so you can
actually go to the planning website
download all the plans for the building
and take a look for yourself and so i
actually downloaded the plans for this
thing so here's a is one of the artist's
impressions of what the building's going
to look like and the important point
about it is that the south facing
surface is curved to this building this
particular architects like making these
concave surfaces so it's actually it's
it has the uninspiring official name of
20 fence church street because that's
its address it's become widely known
amongst londoners as the walkie-talkie
building although they now seem to be
changing it to the walky scorchy
building
but just because it looks a little bit
like an old-fashioned walkie-talkie so
the issue is that
a concave surface
is essentially a way of concentrating
light a concave especially i mean i
guess the important point is that that
uh if the la if the sunlight that were
hitting this surface all just went into
the building that would be fine because
then the building would actually have no
real effect um but even with you know
really uh good quality glass some of the
light gets reflected rather than going
into through the windows and actually as
the light gets more and more oblique
because the angle that the light hits
the glass gets more and more oblique
typically more and more of the light
gets reflected so if the light's coming
in at a
fairly uh shallow angle to the glass
it's much more likely to get reflected
if the lights face on it tends to go
straight through
and so as soon as you have light not
face onto the glass you're going to have
a large amount of it reflected and
because this surface is curved that's
actually going to then focus the light
just as a concave mirror would so i had
a little bit of a play around because i
knew from the news story what time this
guy had parked his car and so you can
then look up in these things called
ephemeris where the sun was in the sky
at that particular time so i could
figure out where the sun was it was
pretty much due south so it was
illuminating this particular surface
pretty much face on but also what angle
it was at so you can figure out how high
in the sky it was
and then you could do this thing called
ray tracing of essentially figuring out
where the different bits of sunlight
would go just using these simple laws of
geometric optics of the light traveling
in a straight line unless it hits a
surface and then the important law you
have to use here is the law of
reflection which just basically says
that the angle of incidence is equal to
the angle of reflection in other words
if the light comes in at a particular
angle it goes off at the same angle so i
just downloaded this started figuring
out where the light went just doing it
with a pencil on the protractor one of
these things from measuring angles and
actually the hardest part of this was
finding a protractor because no one has
one anymore but i did actually manage to
borrow one
okay yeah so actually i actually went
around all the students
saying can i borrow a protractor uh the
general response i got was what's a
protractor which is a bit worrying but
actually it turned out one of them had
this rather fancy looking protractor
stuck on the end of a ruler in his desk
so here's what's going on at that
particular time of day so here's the
sunlight coming in and the sun's a long
way away which essentially means the
rays are all parallel because the rays
are sort of diverging from the sun in
different directions but the sun's
sufficiently far away that to all
intents and purposes they're parallel
here and you can see they strike
different bits of the building and then
you can figure out the angle that they
strike that particular bit of glass at
and hence where any reflected light is
going to go because this angle in has to
be equal to that angle out and because
the building is curved the angles get
different at different points in the
building and that's what causes this
concentration effect
that each one individually is just
getting reflected back the same way it
came pretty much or the sort of
complementary angle to the way it came
but those angles are all different
because the angle of the surface they're
hitting is all different and so you can
see the net effect is that all this well
spread out sunlight coming in ends up
concentrated in a rather small area
and i did some very very crude
calculations to try and figure out how
much it's concentrated by i reckon it's
probably about a factor of 10 to 20. so
the intensity of light on that
particular little bit of road was about
10 to 20 times what the usual intensity
of sunlight is and it turns out for the
plastic parts of car that's enough to
melt them this can be a useful property
of curved oh it's you know it's in
astronomy we use it all the time it's
how you focus the light in a telescope
and in fact the reason why i got
involved in doing these kind of
calculations in the first place is
because the people who wanted to figure
out what these effects were going to be
thinking well who is it who knows what
the properties of large reflecting
concave surfaces are and it's actually
what astronomers do all the time we use
this to actually collect large amounts
of light and focus them down to small
regions when you're looking at a distant
galaxy that's a good thing to do because
you really want to collect as much light
as you possibly can and even when you've
collected all that light it's still very
faint when you're talking about the sun
you've got to be a lot more careful
because there's a lot of light to start
with so when you start concentrating it
down you really get huge amounts of
power
tell us about your form here and not
so i i am this the dubious privilege of
having created an urban myth here in
nottingham
and the urban myth i created is in the
middle of nottingham there's a thing
called the sky mirror which is a
beautiful piece of art it's a concave
mirror put there by an artist called
anish kapoor who makes these kind of
installations quite a lot it's about six
meters in diameter it's a large concave
mirror and it basically reflects the sky
so when you walk into this square
outside the playhouse in the middle of
nottingham you see this amazing mirror
basically reflecting the skyline and the
sky above you and you get these nice
inverted images it's one of the
properties of a concave mirror as the
images come out upside down obviously
there are these health issues associated
with large concave mirrors potentially
in direct sunlight
so i was called into this project to say
well you know what are the issues and i
went through a lot you know what we've
just been talking about about the
dangers of collecting large amounts of
sunlight and what have you even with
them this relatively modest mirror
something six meters across you're still
talking about many many kilowatts of
power potentially being concentrated
into a very small region so you really
got to be very careful about it it turns
out in this particular case that they've
been quite clever about sighting it so
it's not a huge issue so unlike this
skyscraper where it's a south face
that's you know really facing the sun
this mirror is designed to face north
which really means you very rarely get
direct sunlight on it but there are a
few weeks of the year in the middle of
summer when the sun creeps around far
enough that you do have to worry about
it
and so i warned them about all these
issues and they actually then decided
that they were going to put in some
mitigation which was to put some
sunshades up on the top of the theater
as a way of you know preventing the
sunlight getting onto the front face of
the mirror now to do that they needed to
put in a planning application and so
they do they put in the planning
application one of the things that the
people on the local newspaper here in
nottingham do is they go through all the
planning applications to see if there's
anything interesting they found this one
for sun shades they got in touch with
the architects the architect said oh
we'll talk to this astronomy he'll tell
you about it and it was a friday
afternoon and i was you know fairly laid
back with my feet up on the desk talking
to this reporter and just in passing i
said you've got to be very careful about
these things because if you weren't then
a passing pigeon could end up being
barbecued as it flew through the beam
and clearly it was a slow news day in
nottingham so this ended up being the
banner headline on the front page of the
newspaper about barbecued pigeons and
the guys on the wire service nationally
who go through all the local newspapers
looking for entertaining stories and
they picked up on this one and so they
put it out on the wire surface
nationally and internationally and
clearly it was a slow news day
nationally and internationally and i
ended up being interviewed on the bbc
and the story appeared in australian
newspapers and it was all over the place
um and the poor playhouse who'd actually
paid for this wonderful piece of art to
be put out started getting all this
abuse about the way they were
mistreating pigeons and so they ended up
having to produce leaflets that said you
know no pigeons were harmed in the
production of this piece of art and
actually the the chef in the playhouse
because there's a restaurant in the
playhouse has clearly had a sense of
humor because he put barbecue pidgin on
the menu but even now what ten years
after this
i still once in a while people hear
people talking about this mirror
barbecuing pigeons i really have created
my very own urban myth